thanks Daniella and thank you for coming
so if we haven't met I'm near and I'm
going to tell you about time work
puzzles from randomized encodings and
this is joint work with Chef ego Vassar
Abhishek Jane or piness if you note
welcome to nuttin and Brent waters so
let me start with a concept of time
released encryption that was introduced
by May and further developed by your
veterinarian Wagner and this is
basically go vasseur McCauley meets
marty mcfly and doc brown probabilistic
encryption meets time travel ok what we
want to do here is encrypt to the future
ok you want to encrypt to the future ok
so this sounds are pretty cool but what
do I really mean by encrypting to the
future so we know how to encrypt but
what we'd like to do is encrypt in a way
so that everyone can open our encryption
but only after a certain amount of time
that's us that then krypter specified as
a lapse ok so other than cool this this
also seems a pretty useful for example
you can try to you that the auctions in
order to steal your bids or in digital
for teens to the votes you can encrypt
to the future your diary so that your
secrets will only be revealed after you
die right and there are many more very
nice applications that you can find in
the literature ok so there are basically
two approaches to go about this problem
one relies on untrusted parties and the
other one which I'm going to focus on
today doesn't assume any trusted parties
and relies on this very nice notion of
time lock puzzles ok let me tell you
what time of puzzles are
so the syndics is very similar to that
of encryption we have basically an
encryption algorithm that generates so
it possibly takes a message m and some
time t and it generates this puzzle why
do we call the puzzle because it's not
exactly a cipher anyone can solve it
there's this public decryption algorithm
and you don't need any secret key what
you need is time ok so if you have
enough time if you run for enough time
you can recover the message m from this
puzzle now the encryption so important
we can do it very fast ok essentially
independently of d tits it's immediate
now what is the security requirement
here what do we really want here so I
don't want anyone to be able to open the
message before time TS pass so a dresser
is one in time significantly less than T
should not be able to learn the message
or even any information about the
message you can imagine its similarity
to secure but furthermore want this to
even hold for a dresser is over you know
very resourceful perhaps with multiple
cores or normally many we still don't
want them to get any information about
the message and more generally we're
going to think about circuits our
adversaries are going to be circuits
that have arbitrary point normal size in
some security parameter that could
potentially be larger than T the number
of the width can be larger than key but
their depth your parallel time is
shorter than T ok so this is the the
adversary's that will have in mind and
these are time lock puzzles and if you
have time of puzzles you can encrypt to
the future ok so let me tell you a
little bit about existing constructions
for these creatures and actually I'm not
going to be able to tell you about
constructions because we have only one
we have a single construction for this
creature it's a very elegant
shin-bi Rivest Shamir in de and wagner
it's worth knowing if you haven't
encountered at it yet so I'm actually
going to tell you about it we'll see how
it looks and also get a better sense of
this notion okay so how do you encrypt
to the future in their scheme so the
encryption algorithm takes the message
and the time T and it's going to
generate an RSA number and the product
of two large primes and also a random
number r mod n and now in order to pad
our message what we're going to do is
we're going to compute this R to the
power of 2 to the T modern now if I
generate these puzzles ourselves and we
know the factors p and q of n so we know
your order of the multiplicative blue 5n
and we can actually do this very fast we
can first compute to to the t mod 5n
this only requires roughly lochte
squaring and this gives us all that we
need in order to generate as possible on
the other hand if you don't know p and q
if you only get n you know computing 5n
is hard in fact it is as hard as a as
factoring but you can still do squaring
model n of this are here but it will
take you t square x the question is
whether you can do more than that and
you can conjecture that note that this
thing is really inherently sequential
and indeed the best we can do here the
best that we that we know is really to
assume that this thing as is really
security it's inherently sequential you
cannot hope to paralyze this we don't
really have the reduction ok to
factoring or even to RC okay but we have
strong intuition ok
so this is the only construction that we
have and the question is why only one
okay can we come up yeah Rachel you had
a question the functionality of time of
puzzles yeah
okay are you going to die in 50 years in
15 years onward uh-huh okay encrypt into
15 years like basically yes but you know
you can think about more sophisticated
things perhaps no no you can give some
secret key to someone you trust I don't
know but yes basically yes okay you're
going to put it in a lock for 100 years
you decide on the time okay so back o
question why only one constructions we
want more candidates can we have more
candidates and can we actually come up
with with proofs of security no to more
typical cryptographic assumptions like
like those before you sleep and let's
try to understand better the difficulty
here so what exactly is it that we're
looking for so first we're looking for
problems that are inherently sequential
also in the average case okay and you
know if you think about typical
cryptographic problem i know and i even
camp say invert a one-way function on
the range that has size related to t
then this won't really cut it because
it's extremely parallelizable okay so
this is the first challenge actually
finding things that are hard to paralyze
on the average case but even even if you
have this it's still not enough it's
really important that we have this
ability to quickly come up with this
puzzle together with the solution you
know so that we can encrypt whatever
message that we want okay so for example
even if we believe that save some
iterated hash function I don't know shop
is really inherently sequential it's
still not enough because we don't have
any way of speeding it up we don't have
any trap door in this thing we really
need something that we had in the end
RSW construction where we can compute it
fast
given some trapdoor information okay and
these two properties are sort of elusive
kind of hard to come by and surly
question of where we should look for
those things and I'd like to point out
that you know typical cryptographic
assumptions probably won't cut it okay
we need more here and the thing is now
if you look at that standard or people
of cryptographic assumptions and our
adversarial model it doesn't really say
anything about parallelism it doesn't
say anything about this all the
adversary is fall into this pool of
polynomial size and you know taking to
the extreme it could be that we have
crypto we have one-way functions perhaps
even is too much ability obfuscation and
yet everything is parallelizable okay in
a very strong sense okay so of course
that we don't believe that everything is
paralyzed abow okay but this is just to
make the point that some assumption okay
regarding a non paralyzed ability okay
outside of the typical crypto that you
know seems necessary okay there's really
complexity theoretic barrier here okay
so let me tell you still at a very high
level what we show
so what we essentially show is how you
can we give new constructions and
actually a new approach to constructing
time of puzzles we show how you can
separate the cryptic component to you
know a typical crypto component like
like we know and like and as I said we
also need some complexity assumption and
some minimal complexities and with these
two components will construct new time
work puzzles this is still at the very
high level and now need to tell you what
is the cryptic component okay what is
this some chain and what is the
construction okay yes yes yes oh sorry
word at the end the crypto is
essentially you need actually crypto
placed one REE functions yes many be not
equal to n see this is a recent
that what you need really since it p is
not equal to n see for example or was it
just an example well kind of puzzles
already imply some sort of nonprofits
right if you can paralyze everything
easy put nominal time like something the
public is infinitely a time eventually
like yes yes we're thinking about for
you know meal time yes yes everything is
point no meal time thing about precise
notion of security okay I'm going to
start with the with the crypto component
and this is a randomized encoding
something that Benny talked about our
quite elaborate lean the in the boot
camp but let me remind you what those
are so in a randomized encoding scheme
we have two algorithms and encoder and a
decoder and we would like to take a
computation say given by some cheering
machine and an input and encoded in some
way it's a randomized encoding in order
to have the following properties so
first the Cinco de computation can be
decoded by this public order again you
don't need any additional information
for that and the decoder can retrieve
the result of the complication now what
is crucial here is that we want then
coder to be significantly simpler than
the computation itself ok and when we'll
get to this point in a bit the coating
on the other hand can be as complex as
the the computation it's ok what will we
want in in terms of security so in terms
of security will basically want that
this encoding doesn't reveal anything
about the computation except for the
final result ok you can send this
machine in putting the clear really has
to reveal nothing but the output in
other words you can simulate this
encoding just from the output and let's
say the time of the competition ok this
is also something go the clicks and for
the purpose of this talk I don't really
care if this simulator is efficient or
not efficient
bo food ok so now too simple what does
simple mean here and simple could have
different meanings different
interpretations so Benny talked mostly
about then coding being shallow or local
ok but there are also other complexity
measures that you can think about and in
this talk I'm going to focus on a very
specific one I'm going to require that
encoding is very fast ok and with these
fast randomized encoding we're going to
get full fledged panic puzzles but let
me already say here that even if you
start from wicker notion of time Apollo
of randomized encodings you still get
some time Apollo's weaker notions of
time of puzzles but we're still seeing
meaningful ok but again today we're
going to focus on this thing ok so what
are faster randomized encoding also
knowing 16 randomized encoding as you
know it is just the encoding is very
fast the time to encode is significantly
shorter say independent of the time of
the computation the coding takes the
same time functionality is sorry
security as before simply simulation do
we have this thing well can we construct
it so at this point at least we only
know how to construct it from in this
demotion ability application it's pretty
a strong object but as far as we know it
could be weaker I'm going to touch this
point again atty ok so this is the
crypto component and in fact before I
tell you what is the complexity
assumption I'm going to jump right ahead
to the construction because it's really
simple and actually it's not going to
depend on the on the assumption itself
ok let me tell you what it is and then
we'll develop some intuition about what
the assumption should be what is the
complexity assumption
with the previous slide so this
construction of Education I just maybe
just to get more familiar with what's
the intuition world is a simplest
construction from Association take a
gate garber for your gobble circuit and
obfuscate it just one line to think
about it it's more than that it just
desk for a sentence okay so i want to
scribe the construction the new tunnel
puzzle the first thing we need to do is
say what is this encryption algorithm
what is it going to be well we're simply
going to encode some computation using
the 16th randomized encoding and output
this encoding then what is this
computation that we're going to encode
or in fact it could be any long
computation that has a very specific
property for example we can think about
a computation that makes T dummy steps
absolutely nothing forty timestamps and
then it then it's going to output the
messaging okay so this is basically our
toilet puzzle simple no randomized
encoding of this computation notice that
this is a very fast of course the
randomized encoding is fast exactly what
we need how do you solve the puzzle
while we just run the decoder for the
randomized encoding right we know the
decoder can retrieve the output good
okay this can be done in time T which is
okay
okay so clearly has the functionality
that we need but let's try to get some
intuition and why this thing is really
secure why does it really give us so
what we need why can you expect it to
give us what we okay to remember that
our randomized encoding our puzzle here
each machine which can be vision do you
do the randomizer couldn't it's a
computation that does nothing 40 steps
okay can ignore the input for every
input it's very lazy and then at the end
it outputs the message am now in
particular this encoder computation is
not supposed to reveal by the security
of the randomized encoding anything but
the output by the message m so it should
be indistinguishable from any other
encoded computation right as long as
this other computation also outputs and
at the end and say has the same number
of steps okay now well we know that this
computation really does nothing okay and
then i'll put them as far as we know
this other computation could be
something arbitrary in particular it
could solve an inherently sequential
problem federal some iterated hash or
any other thing that you might believe
to be non paralyzed about okay the
answer you cannot tell as long as these
two at the end up with the same message
m it cannot tell so with this intuition
in mind we can really start thinking
what should be the complexity assumption
that we need because there seems to be a
very nice universality property here we
don't really care that anything specific
is inherently sequential all that we
care is that there's some you know
inherently sequential computations in
the world and then we can plug them here
ok select me now yes
addition it gives em as a result yes yes
yes yes ok so I'm going to wrap this
whatever non paralyzed with computation
ok just output enmity and the randomized
encoding sort of wall them together this
is duh it's sorry at the end the M is
not is independent of the input every
independent firm Frank EXT yes yes yes
yes ok there's now is this intuition in
mind we can really define what is our
assumptions that what is our assumption
and her something is essentially that
not everything is paralyzing ok there
are computations that cannot be
paralyzed a little more formally for any
point on the time function and say a
constant Delta smaller than one we want
a language that on one hand you can
decide it in time t even see punctually
ok but you cannot paralyze it ok so
circuits that have depth significantly
less than T safety to the Delta will
fail to decide it first kiss Alicia Keys
good so first comment if granny this is
worst-case all that we care is that
every circuit fails for some input
another thing is that this is necessary
really if you think about it panic
puzzles imply non paralyzing languages
even in the average case and the first
thing is that this is really something
that that we widely believed okay we
don't believe that everything is
paralyzed abow okay it's a natural
generalization of the assumption that p
is not equal to 2 n.c yes why don't you
mention this is
money are dumb wha anchor this
generalized blah blah of assumption that
under which you can so the blood blonde
shop is really similar to the photos
haha maybe you can tell me about this at
the end LOL rona so is it it's a
different assumption than the RSW it
also gives you tons of puzzles okay
maybe it's not inherently different okay
you can tell me at the end things ok so
now estate we state the domain result
basically the crypto components 16
randomized encoding and the complexity
theoretic assumption 9 paralyzing
languages imply time lock puzzles ok and
I can say two words about the proof just
to get even a better sense what's going
on really follow the intuition that we
had we want to show that if we have a
shallow circuit that can break our time
of puzzle right let's say for simplicity
really recover the message and for some
random message m in time significantly
in depth significantly less than now T
what we'd like to do is sort of a worse
taste your average case reduction what
we like to do is show that you can
construct from this guy and decider the
decide some nan paralyzing language L in
the worst case okay and how is it going
to work well we're simply going to run
the reduction is simply going to run
this decide on some encoded computation
and what does this computation do it
take the the instance we want to decide
it decides the instance this is
something that we know we can do in
sequential time T and if Indians is in
the language it will output a random
message otherwise it won't output
anything now at this point we know that
this guy would produce a message and
we're going to say that this instance
prize in the language only if it really
got our randomness
then coded message and why does this
work so first again note that this guy
shallow we know that this guy's fast or
this entire thing is really shallow like
we want so it really breaks the Denard
parallelism and the inclusion is really
going back to the picture that we just
had okay if really the diocese is in the
language then we know that this encoded
computation here is really
indistinguishable from the outer puzzles
because it will output em at the end
this is in the language so M will be
outputted you cannot distinguish them we
know that in this case the shallow
circuits recovers in so which will also
recover recover em in this case okay
when sighs not in the language then we
know that this guy at the end will
output nothing right so this encoded
computation is really indistinguishable
from a computation that has no
information at all about it just outputs
nothing at the end so in particular from
this thing you cannot recover the
message look this is the idea this is
really sort of an average case to
worst-case reduction using randomized
encodings okay anything that the sort of
universality property here that you
really get from the randomized encoding
is sort of nice okay it's really kind of
special so you might have an adversary's
with life takes something arbitrary to
you choose just not to message him yes
but the size of the tuition so the size
is small market basically to fix that
your machine may be very slowly but just
to make sure that they may be the things
will grow here with the security
parameter but not with tea sure okay so
decides is lovely no no no no everything
yes yes everything depends on the
security parameter I'm pushing it under
the carpet but it is advantage to use a
like pickled pig language instead look
like you get to the society for free
because of the hiding focus right we
don't really care right we don't use any
specific language in some sense yes
maybe like a topic with the security
like in this thing if use the pickle
click thing ever you get some sort okay
that's the question haven't thought
about it yeah you're saying instead of
this lazy computation use some very
specific computation i'm not sure but
need to think about it okay so let me
just mention that in the paper actually
we have a couple of photo results
already mentioned that you can get the
wicker time look puzzles from wicker
randomized encodings okay which in turn
you can get from wicker assumptions okay
so even say the randomized encodings
that we know how to construct from
one-way functions okay in which the just
the depth of the encoding a small would
still give you a meaningful time to
puzzle where the depth of generating a
puzzle is small but still competing it
acquires sequential time there's a
caveat there but yes shy you just relax
the
gap between the sequential scales so if
you if you assume weaker weaker non
paralyzed ability would get a weaker in
a time of puzzle the construction
doesn't change this is something nice
right did you get the construction from
something bigger than I oh right I don't
know how to relax the cryptography I
would only know how to relax the
complexity assumption so when you say we
could a fine book puzzles meantime
Lopez's little creative requires a lot
of time right i mean that's creating
then may require a lot of time but they
can be paralyzed actually in this
solution there's another caveat will get
a very large bubble you can paralyze it
but it looks very large so verbal
suitcase you exactly exactly okay and
another point is you can actually try to
apply this approach to different type of
of puzzles so for example to two proofs
of work by token or you will have an
equivalent of non paralyzing language
will have none or tising languages but
basically the same idea would work and
final thing your question alone we can
show that tunnel puzzles duel acquire
some crypto at least one wave functions
it's not too surprising it's interesting
to see if you requires more ok this
strong notion of timer buzzes I don't
know okay yes so the register and the
mice and coatings which don't require
are you which are not quite sexy buxom
lip online offline right of like right
right does it give you interesting thing
like if you just applied the yells or
someone yes so we mentioned it will give
you an interesting thing but a lot of
the full 50 you would be able you would
say that some gap between the person
that generates the puzzle and the person
that needs to solve the puzzle now the
person degenerates will be parallel
where this guy must be sequential
like he can you do something or if it
was no like I have worked for 10 years
they expect to pull some food the result
in 10 years I worked on the side for 10
years to generate something then
eventually get the result and now I can
produce this yes you can also you can
also sort of use the reusable gobble
circuit to it there is there is play
there are other places to gain here
don't just so i can tell you in detail
perhaps so far i guess my question is
your framework it looks like a very boo
framework can by plugging different and
amazing yes definitely results if you
just blood you get new results you get
your results I don't think that's this
thing that was for a cheesy you get the
result that take perhaps a lot of time
to create but at least it's a single so
I don't know how to do this from fhe
alone without having an extra component
we can show that if you have fhe you can
sort of give up on the sick on the
secrecy of the computation and use
something like a message hiding encoding
that only hides the message i can
discuss it for you i think there is a
result that you haven't mentioned right
about from mohamed and other aesthetic
the moody about impossibility in the
random article model there's also a
possibility in the random work i want to
write something about the question
whether you can do this remotely
functions right this is not like no
sense okay so so when the random Oracle
model there are some additional results
actually not full fledged time no
puzzles there are weaker forms of time
lock puzzles there also some negative
results that concern the random Oracle
model and fig this ideal notion I'm not
sure that we say anything about the
plane model but maybe something it does
look like the production
think about it I'll think about it it's
a good point right okay so just before I
end quickly mention two to open things
one is really come up with other
constructions of time work puzzles our
construction uses this strong object of
16 randomized encoding which brings me
to the to the next thing how strong is
this thing really is okay and here
without spoiling the the next talk okay
I I want to stress that something that
seems to be quite crucial about this
these randomized encodings is where they
depend on the output of the computation
or not can you actually make the
encoding smaller than the output of the
computation this turns out to be a
pretty crucial and I want to note that
here we don't need this okay it's really
near so this notion of a friend amazing
cookies okay so this is all I wanted to
say I think thank you